okay so I guess I'm doing another one of
these as you've probably heard from the
one I did Sonic the Hedgehog trailer I
don't I'm not really huge into like
trailer reactions and not not that I'm
against anyone that doesn't mat all I
mean like I get it there's a lot to
analyze I actually really love trailers
just my reactions aren't really that big
but people really liked the sonic one
and I'm just seeing if people like these
maybe they do maybe they don't
I will say I had to just do with ones I
feel like I can actually talk about cuz
sometimes a trailer will come up what do
you think it's just it didn't give me
much I don't know like the trailer
before this spider-man trailer uh I'm
gonna be able to say much about I mean
it didn't leave much of an impact on me
so you know but this one I feel like I
can talk about a little bit so if so I
don't know if I'm gonna keep doing these
or not this is kind of it experimenting
with it seeing if you know if they're
fun if I like doing if you guys like
them so but I'm doing this one because I
saw the trailer I saw people like you
know seem to enjoy my sonic reaction and
this one I feel like I can talk about
cuz there is some stuff that was like
ooh like I was gonna put on Facebook
post or something else like I could just
talk about it so okay with that said
goes without saying
endgame spoilers obviously even the
trailer has that end game spoilers you
know so if those who know or don't know
uh the one before this homecoming I
thought was okay people at the time
seemed to think it was like the best
spider-man movie ever but then the
spider verse came out just thank God for
spider first it's just we finally got
like a great spider-man movie like just
perfect great spider-man movie so we
finally got that uh and I wasn't looking
forward to this far from home when I was
just so like okay it's just another
spider-man film but but there's one
thing they're doing I was hoping they
were gonna do and it looks like they're
doing it I hope they follow all the way
through like that that's really my hope
it kind of looks like they're making
Tony Stark Uncle Ben and I'm really ok
with that even though you could argue
like but I'll go back as Uncle Ben don't
do that but it's like they say
we've seen that Ben get axed off you
know so many times we seem get bitten by
the spider so many times so even though
I was kind of indifferent to homecoming
like I know why they did the changes
that they did and they were smart you
know I just didn't think that justified
like a great you know spider-man movie
um but here now kind of like a
homecoming is becoming a little bit more
justified because they're building up
the connection between him and Stark and
they're kind of making a kind of like he
was the uncle character and I think what
that does now is that give spider-man
purpose it gives him a reason to be
spider-man it seems like he's really
having trouble with it in the trailer
he's just like you know me ever since
you know Tony died I just don't know
what what to think or what to do I I
mean and people are talking about him
replacing spider-man's like know our
place in Ironman it's like I'm not an
Iron Man on spider-man all this stuff so
now sorry my cats acting weird so now we
kind of have this we have a reason for
spider-man to be spider-man
even though it kind of happened a little
after he was spider-man it still kind of
feels like okay there's like a reason
for him to be here there's a reason for
him to be doing what he's doing because
I still never fully got why he did
before again it just seemed I want to be
like Iron Man but even that is kind of
working now because they're working it
into you know just kind of this fun
little thing he wanted to do to suddenly
now you have weight to what you do you
have like this real you have this
responsibility so I really really dig
that I hope that's the angles are really
gonna focus on here you know it really
fingers crossed on that cuz like if
that's a way of taking this sort of new
spin on spam I mean not that new but but
new enough where we don't have Uncle Ben
and sort of doing something very similar
keeping true to the character just
changing the details and I'm very okay
with that
it looks like Mary Jane knows who's
fighter man is and I wonder people gonna
be like the spoiler when she says
everything's a friggin spoiler now
but I actually thought that was kind of
funny that they reveal that in the
trailer unless it's another one of those
like fake outs like nah just kidding you
could possibly be spider-man if they do
that I'm gonna be pissed because yeah
that's always one of the things where
it's like oh come on just let them find
out because we know they're gonna find
out at some point you know in the early
days with Lois Lane and everything that
was fine but you know they're gonna find
out so just jump right to it and like if
Marvel's usually pretty smart and
looking ahead of that stuff
it'll still be interesting to see what
they do with with her because she's so
cynical and again I'm kind of okay with
doing like a different spin but it's
like it's like Daria you know where Mary
Jane I mean I don't know if I've ever
seen Mary Jane done right I mean like
they always try it's like they always
get kind of a general idea but it's
always a little too corny where it's
always a little too up I mean I like I
feel like this is someone that's just
like she's had like a kinda like rogue
she's had like a rough life and so she
takes it and turns into just this super
extrovert personality where she's just
like really having fun let's go out
there you know that this you know red
hair Spitfire you know just let's go do
it kind of thing which is like that
that's a cool character and that's a
very likeable character but she OE she's
a little too corny in the 90s cartoon
and it's just really corny and the live
in the rainy woods but everybody was
really corny they're so um so be
interesting what they do with this I'm
just hoping there's like legit chemistry
there and I'm hoping they I mean it
might work because he's so the opposite
I mean that's always kind of the thing
is that you know that they're supposed
to be a little opposite so he's kind of
shy and reserved a little dorky and
she's I mean if she's a little dorky too
but she's a little bit more cynical it's
got a little bit more of an edge to her
you know so that that can be interesting
I'm open to that even though it's like
it's kind of a shame where I don't know
for ever again get our cinematic Mary
Jane you know the way like she was in
the comics um what else what else I
don't know much about the villain like
I've seen him in comics I know the dome
and everything uh
it's very interesting that they're
talking about parallel dimensions which
alike okay it they've done that before
they've done it before into the
spider-verse but now it's like yeah the
best spider-man movie ever I mean like
people a lot being like hands down this
is the best one into the spider-verse
deals with multiple universes parallel
universes so it's like hmm
but again knowing how they have to plan
these movies like freakin far ahead I
mean this could be like something that
was like very has planned but it is
interesting I'm assuming they'll do
something different with it it would be
really weird it's certainly like Tobey
Maguire's Piderman from a different
universe but maybe he'll bring the x-men
in and I'll get that reboot going so I
don't know I I'm a little thrown off by
them saying like you know he's gonna be
the new Iron Man like that's a little
weird it's it's a little soon it's a
little too soon but I don't know it's
it's the first time I've seen one of
these like in terms of the MCU you know
where I've seen a spider-man trailer I'm
like very interesting like that as
promised where the other ones like it
said they just looked like or that the
first one was just another spider-man
movie and the teaser before this one
just looks like another Spiderman movie
but this is the first one where it looks
like they're really adding something
that was missing from spider-man not
only missing but going back and kind of
fixing the problem that was there before
with not having Uncle Ben and having too
much focus on Tony Stark you know like
they're sort of taking that and really
turning it into something something
really important like something that was
missing from spider-man so I'm really
excited about that
um I think that's about it I mean
everything else about just sort of looks
like an okay beam web-swing he's got the
new suit the new suits cool
I'm glad like he keeps the suit and
again it helps give this spider-man a
little bit more of an identity like his
own identity and it's a cool suit he
does cool stuff you know in the infinity
war an end game I was just
that's pretty cool I want to see what
else that thing can do because we've
seen the Aspire man stuff so much
against why spider-verse was great
because it gave us different types of
spider men women kids robots like you
like all this stuff so I like that
they're throwing in these other options
in there and I'm sure it's from the
comic I mean that that design it's way
too good to not be from a comic so yeah
that's about it I'm it's the first time
I've seen a MCU spider-man where I'm
like excited you know to see what they
do with it because it's really adding
this depth that was I felt missing from
it so yeah that's about it uh we'll see
if I do more of these I I don't know if
there's gonna be like a regular thing or
if this only be the second one I don't
know uh but I stand by it has to be a
trailer I can talk about like I'm
passionate to talk about guy I know I
can ramble but it's like I really gotta
have an interest in it you know so yeah
that's about it and we'll see if there's
more of these and we'll see how this
movie turns out later
you